foreign
what you got going on Andrew
Hi how are you both doing doing good how
are you
I'm doing I'm doing good
um first thank you for taking my call
giving me a chance to help me with my
question absolutely
should they put uh in the last four to
six months or so I got really caught up
just inflating my lifestyle and now
pretty much got myself in a let's say
bad car situation I'm really just trying
to get out of it oh no tell us about it
what's going on
so um I got a new car that at the time I
felt like I could handle the monthly
payments but uh it kind of just feels
like you know don't have much of a cash
flow and uh uh it's just I really at
this point I'm so I'm sold on selling
the car and the question I have for you
guys is like is it better for me to buy
a car and cash help pay down a bit
faster or Finance something like at a
third of the cost that would keep
forever what do you think we're going to
tell you
buy a car in cash yeah
yeah why do you well I'm just playing
devil's advocate here because I want to
see I want to make sure that you know
the reason why because you're feeling
the pinch of this car payment how much
is your car payment Andrew
eleven hundred dollars a month
you're feeling that yeah because I mean
that's above how much you make a year
I make about last year I made a little
over 100 this year I'm gonna try to make
about 120. okay
so you've had the car for three months
and now you're thinking this was a bad
idea so to Jade's question
why do you think that we
are going to suggest to pay for your
next car with cash and not take out
another loan
um
well so I no longer have a monthly
payment and you know help me save up
faster
um and I and yeah that's that's pretty
much my
to give you some some background spots
why I wasn't even think of the other
option
um is really uh my I've heard you guys
give the advice before I've told people
you know go buy a three thousand five
thousand dollar car write it and then uh
help you pay down the cash but I I'm I'm
wondering if if that uh like I'm I'm
worried that I'm gonna get a car like
that and then you know three six months
it's gonna have a lot of payments so
it's gonna have to like a lot of fixes
or something and then end up doing the
same thing again I think as long as you
I think it's look I've I've only I've
only driven used cars I've never had a
brand new car in my life and I think as
long as you do the research check out
the Carfax find out as much as you can
about the car and and make a solid
purchase that's thing one and then thing
two we always talk about having an
emergency fund your emergency fund is
there in case something crazy goes wrong
right there's that and then your third
level of protection is you know always
having a sinking fund just sitting there
for regular car maintenance so that
you're taking care of your vehicles and
and you're doing the things like the oil
changes and the tires and changing the
the belts and all I don't know all the
car terminology but you're doing great
Jade you're you're selling me on it you
know the rotator cuff you know whatever
it's called I don't know what that is
but as long as you're the alternator
there you go as long as you are taking
care of your vehicle as long as you have
your emergency fund set aside I think
it's really easy to focus on those
horror stories and and let it talk you
out of doing what's right but I know
plenty of people who have bought new
cars and they've had car troubles so I
think that's just kind of like that that
we hit to me it's gonna be your biggest
here's your biggest hurdle are you ready
your ego okay that's it because
you are sitting in a brand new very
expensive car what kind of car is it
it's a Tesla
yeah
this is close to Rachel's heart now
I will have a moment of silence
I'm so sorry but listen you're gonna
it's gonna hurt your ego is Gonna Hurt
you've been driving around up to work up
with friends going to dinner in your new
Tesla and now you're gonna show up in a
Camry that's right and your ego's gonna
take a hit but you know what
guess what you're Andrew's gonna have
money again okay Andrew's gonna have
money and that's what you have to focus
on Andrew it's amazing how we just get
so much of we were talking about the
consumerism in the last hour but it's
true I'm like man this this lifestyle
feel and somehow we think if I just had
a nice car uh if I just could go on this
kind of trip if I could have this kind
of house everything will be better I'm
gonna feel better about myself because
our cars have become our identity people
look at your car yeah and they
automatically you know they make a
Solutions make assumptions and so it
takes a level of humility Andrew to say
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna help
Andrew 10 years from now yeah be in a
whole lot better shape to go buy a new
Tesla my goal for you Andrew is to go
back to a new Tesla I would love for you
yes love for you to be an everyday
millionaire be investing have no debt
cash flow coming in you're making great
money and to be like yeah you know what
I'm gonna go buy a new Tesla and you
don't have to think twice about it come
on drive like no one else so later you
can drive like nowhere follow Andrew
that's the goal but this thing is eating
you alive so you're gonna take a hit on
it you're probably gonna be underwater
by buying it brand new and selling it
three months later so you're gonna take
a small loan outs for that difference
put that in your debt snowball go buy a
cheap car with three thousand five
thousand dollars it's fine and if it
breaks down in six months guess what it
doesn't lose value go sell it for three
thousand dollars more put a few more go
to go get another car right like you can
keep moving up in car but list out all
of your debts Andrew knock it all out
you have a great income get a solid
emergency fund and your peace of mind
Andrew your peace of mind is going to be
so different because you're actually
going to have peace you're not gonna
have stress I love that you got it you
got it Andrew but I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
he has to amputate the Tesla it's never
an easy thing to do but he's gonna have
peace because of it look your car is not
your status symbol it does not say
whether or not you are successful or not
what I'm looking at is do you actually
have money Rachel that's right